so there is no freedom because the
people who control the information they
don't want other people to tell the
truth so YouTube has such a monopoly if
you try and launch a competitor to
YouTube you don't last you can't compete
with Google these people control the
internet they control access to and from
the internet they shut you down at will
these people have an absolute Monopoly
and they're not going to give it up why
would you give up a monopoly over
information
these people are never going to give it
up if this video doesn't last on YouTube
where else are we going to put it you
tell me where else we're going to put it
you're telling me something okay your
website right I have friends who have
their own websites and guess what
happens they lose their domain let's
look at Alex Jones look at Alex Jones
look at Alex Jones if you're watching
this and you don't know who Alex Jones
is Alex Jones is a hero and he will
always tell you the truth go and look up
Alex Jones and don't listen to what
Google and YouTube say right you have to
go and dig deep by Alex Jones Alex Jones
is a guy who told the truth all the time
he's a good guy he's a hero of the
American people who never lied YouTube
deleted all this stuff overnight for no
reason not only did they delete all his
stuff if you look up Alex Jones on
YouTube you can't nothing even comes up
about them about a [ __ ] watch Mojo video
and stuff of him in court talking about
the Sandy Hook thing that's that's all
you can see and if you click on any of
the videos you can't even listen to him
talking for more than 30 seconds without
it being completely cut up yeah that
that came up today and again here in the
house with some someone here and I Alex
Jones you know the guy who denied Sandy
Hook and I said did you ever see him and
of course no saw all the the news I said
well I'm gonna be honest maybe he did
maybe he did create a lot of stress and
strain for these people but maybe he
didn't and I I have not had the time
immediately yeah the media did right be
real the media no you're right you're
right the media blew it up and uh I said
I haven't seen it and I told her I told
her that Sonny and I are going to watch
that on the show we want to watch the
find if we can even find it on the dark
web or wherever like full context
episodes of his where we watch it and we
react to it and see for ourselves we're
doing it on on Rumble and my Discord so
make sure you guys join those so you
don't miss them all right that'll be
cool because I really want to do that
and and I may come out of it hating the
guy I don't know but I wanna the whole
point is just don't believe the
headlines don't believe the politicians
everybody's just full of [ __ ] we have to
think believe me when I say you got to
think for yourself
because he kept calling out YouTube on
their blatant lies and they lie and they
control the information if you can
control information you can control
people's minds it's amazing to me now
we'll go on to the election because
that's what they really want to do when
you control people's minds right yeah
when you control people's minds you want
to control who they elect because then
then you control the world now you
control the world right yeah so last
night here I'm just gonna I'm gonna talk
about this because it was so hilarious
yeah I went to bed early and I decided I
don't I got a little hungry I came
downstairs we had company at the kitchen
table and we're sitting there and I just
decided all right I guess I'm up now I
sat down and started talking and our
guest who's a good friend of the family
and a lovely really nice person I'm just
gonna get into she she just started
railing against capitalism with no real
understanding of it whatsoever okay fine
but then she's she her family is from
Puerto Rico and she started talking
about how uh you know Puerto Rico should
have independence from the US and it
should no longer be a territory and you
know and I just started asking questions
because I know not I know a little bit
about it but it's an American territory
but I don't know enough especially from
a person who's you know has all of her
family in Puerto Rico she's a first
generation American spent a lot of time
there and uh she she just started
telling me that you know where there's
there for all the resources uh she said
there's tons of sugarcane and tobacco
and some other stuff and I didn't even
look it up I don't even know if that's
true and then she started saying they
should have Independence and I said
listen if you had Independence if we
just washed our hands walked away in
Puerto Rico if you have all those
resources any other country is just
going to come in and swoop you up and be
far worse to you than the United States
now the reality is if say Russia came in
and we would have to defend Puerto Rico
against Russia because they're so close
to our shore we don't want Russia to be
in charge of anything that close to us
but the real funny thing of here is that
she said and I swear with such passion
and conviction and truly believed it in
her head that if we left them and Russia
invaded Puerto Rico that Puerto Rico on
its own could beat Russia they don't
have an army an Air Force a Navy a coast
guard even they have nothing even if we
left them any old you know they have the
faces and tanks she's she actually yeah
said we have tanks we have this you
don't have an Air Force now well we have
planes okay you have what are stuff
that's there and even if we left it for
you you'd be dead in 15 minutes right
and she's just was just determined
determined is that no matter what Puerto
Rico could beat Vladimir Putin in war
and you really can't like you can't
argue I stayed and and went at it with
her normally I like to get up and walk
away when I'm arguing with somebody that
just has no sense of reality but I
hadn't had an argument in a long time
and I was like I'm kind of in the mood
so I sat there and you know got into it
but this is what we're up against so
when Tate says that they that you you
control information you control people's
minds he couldn't be more more accurate
because the real problem is again they
keep every politician comes and they say
we're going to fix the education system
in the U.S they don't want to fix it
they want you stupid they want you dumb
they want you believe in headlines
without reading anything or doing any
research they actually cared about you
they teach you something about that's
actually like applicable to life you
know they teach you sales they teach you
how to do your taxes they teach you how
you know how to make money they teach
you some financial literacy no no they
are the only ones who want who can have
power and money and then they teach you
to work go get a job go to College by
get take the loan out get that 200k it's
worth it right but then they teach you
to hate the rich hate the rich because
they I want to keep you down College
loan is one of the only loans I think it
is the only loan you can't go bankrupt
on so you're you're giving telling these
18 year olds to go into quarter million
dollar debt at 18 years old how sick is
that in the head what other choice do
you have then when you can't this debt
can't be forgiven you have to go get a
job you're screwed it's a it's it's a
system to suck you in you have to step
back but they are they're at once
telling you to take this loan because
education is most important thing you
can have and at the same time
deliberately keeping us dumb it's the
[ __ ] gaslighting twisting supplies
and everybody's just in it like oh they
care about my education no they [ __ ]
don't yeah they tell you how the [ __ ]
The Whole World's Gonna go underwater
soon all right yeah I [ __ ] wish the
news you see on the TV bring me a water
all the news is always orchestrated and
I'd give you a million examples of that
I am Fox San Antonio's Jessica oh my God
and I'm Ryan Wilson
he says the news is orchestrated TV is
of course fake all the news is always
orchestrated well I'll give you a
million examples of hi I'm Fox San
Antonio's Jessica Headley and I'm Ryan
Wolfe our greatest responsibility is to
serve our Treasure Valley communities
the El Paso Las Cruces communities
Eastern Iowa communities Mid Michigan
communities we are extremely proud of
the quality balanced journalism that CBS
4 News produces but
all this covet thing the idea is that
when I walk into the gas station some
lady which is how this is happening that
is the Free Press Free Press scripted
actors who's writing scripts Bots wow
some ladies can say your mask and start
to panic
but the law is stupid why should we
blindly obey laws that we know that we
know are we sorry because the woman
risks getting fired if she doesn't tell
you that that's right comply what would
you do if you were her fire all of us
speak your [ __ ] mind if everybody
would just everybody I'm still who was
it just
he's talking to somebody that's like you
know what I just don't need to rock the
boat I need to keep my job still [ __ ]
they can't fire all of us if everybody
would just stand up and say listen I'm
gonna speak my mind I'm sick of the [ __ ]
they can't get rid of all this if all of
those news people had the cajones to get
to to stand up and say I'm didn't go to
school and work my whole life to become
a journalist to read this nonsense
script that's full of garbage
if they all just did that they would
have nobody there but you know what the
problem is they know that there's some
other little bot right behind them
that's going to come up and say I'll do
it I'll do it or whatever you say I'll
wear the mask I'll wear the mask I'll
take my shot what's okay like Logan Paul
I'll do it whatever you say if I was I
do exactly what I'm doing now because it
doesn't matter what job I have or how
much money I have it's an individual I
think for myself and I don't give I
don't care if anyone comes along to me
and tells me you must mandate X and I
don't believe in it I would not do it I
am not a slave individual right if
someone comes along and says You must
tell people to wear a mask you know what
I do if someone walked in that mask
pretend I didn't because if everyone was
like me if everybody was like me refused
to wear a mask not insane people that
worked at stores for minimum wage would
have [ __ ] freak attacks over you not
wearing a mask like I remember going to
Ace Hardware and the lady was like
chasing me up the Halls
these are the employees at Ace Hardware
in [ __ ] Seattle what a [ __ ] punk
[ __ ]
look at this [ __ ] what the [ __ ] relax
dude that's grabbing like a light bulb
and you're you're having an aneurysm I
got yelled at in that same Ace Hardware
by a lady who was wearing a mask and I
wasn't before I think it was even
mandated and I was just like and then
even once they got rid of them you're
not afraid of me just Scurry away like
carry on lady the six feet and the way
people were so like like six feet they
would live and die by that I mean the
whole thing was and then go sit next to
each other on the plane like this and
refuse to tell people to wear masks this
whole thing would end they can't keep
the scam up because they can't enforce
it there's not enough police to enforce
the scam more people have died as a
result of Corona lockdowns than
coronavirus itself possibly yeah well we
could say possible yeah okay maybe
Possible Oh my God YouTube it's just my
opinion more people have died from
canceled a point lockdowns Victorian
child's death Spike during coveted
lockdown after series of home accidents
eight children under the age of five die
in two months as kids spend more time at
home wow
okay
people would genuinely become depressed
too because the stuff that you actually
need to not become depressed like the
gym getting a good diet going out
getting exercise they took that all the
way you couldn't go to the gym you
couldn't go to the [ __ ] beach you
suicide rates you couldn't go to the
beach among high schoolers were up 90 in
some districts in Thailand alone more
people died the weekend they reopened
from car accidents then people died the
entire time from covet the negative
effects oh my God the negative effects
outweigh the like the benefits so much
more I mean look at the economy now
that's all because of this that's all
because of this [ __ ] that they were
feeding down our throats that's still
here hasn't gone away more people have
died from canceled appointments in
England there's endless cases of people
who were canceled for cancer
appointments car operations these are
real things
but this is people you have women who
are stuck in maternity Awards by
themselves without their Partners
this whole thing is insane and more
people are dying from the from the
lockdown than lives you're saving how
can you as a government and Australia
I'll send you to link in Australia five
toddlers have died who needed heart
operations in a specific
hospitals the patients
so kids are dying how was a grown-up an
adult can you sit there and see people
dying because of all the lockdown and
then sit there and say oh but for your
safety doesn't matter they can die but
for your safety we're going to keep you
in because we care about people's lives
if you cared about people's lives you
build the health infrastructure right
all the money the economy is losing
could build enough hospitals to deal
with any patient who's sick right they
got much well the world is lost take
this money build a few extra hospitals
and let people live their lives but they
don't care about our safety they don't
care about people's livelihoods they
want to control us that's all they want
to do this is another excuse to exert
control that's all a government has ever
wanted is to exert control there's no
division in the world besides the people
with power and the people without power
you and I right people think we're rich
he's in very beautiful cars I have very
beautiful cars we're free enough to go
where we want but we don't have any
power anytime the government can come
and arrest us police can arrest us they
can stop take your passports we have no
power yes the people with power all they
want to do is make sure the people down
here
never start to think for themselves this
is this is how it's been since the dawn
of time since World War II since before
that it's always been the same Corona is
another excuse to control people there's
a million ways they could help the
population and deal with this Corona
problem not that it's even a problem to
begin with without destroying
livelihoods of individuals and exerting
control it's done absolutely on purpose
because this is a government's answer to
everything ah just give up your freedom
give up more freedom and we'll fix it
just give up a little bit more and we'll
fit especially at the time when we were
already divided so we were like you
could have kicked us while we were down
you know they wanted they wanted to like
keep us that way and keep us but things
were starting to go well in the Trump
Administration people were prospering
families were prospering he gave you
know we had he was doing really well
keeping Russia and North Korea at Bay he
was giving money to he was the only
president and to give he gave all kinds
of money to um the black colleges across
the United States so he was unraveling
their um racism argument all this [ __ ]
was happening that was like the American
people were like all right we're good
we're good everyone was just happy going
about their business and so they had to
ruin it they had to you remember because
Trump said all lives matter that they
came after him like he was the devil he
used to literally be racist for saying
all lives matter it's not crazy you
still are you racist
[Music]
[Music]